[Applause]
Good
morning, Commission President,
dear Ursula and I, not because I
didn't want to,
but every goodbye hurts,
the goodbyes and gone were happy to go
back, the goodbye was sweetened by the
fact that you are my successor in
that sense  i leave myself good to
the one house that is reasonably alright
i express my wish for you
gods blessings on the world and big ears is coming
president needs big ears because he
can't get into this excitement
and there are a lot of houses like that
but he has to have big ears
that  whispering here in the house in the
member states in parliament elsewhere in parliament
i wish you good eyes case the
small print is also important i am
convinced that you will be a good
commission president that
really convinced i can for
many years recently we tried to
find out we want  we met for the first
time
i remember there  ss we are
deeply impressed by our first encounter
but at most when it was
and i am convinced that you
will have the member states together the
duo will continue to drive and that
everything will be fine if you need my bike
you will get it if you don't
need it  him anyway but in a way
that is not considered
statesmanlike and lecturing because
i'm not someone who likes to
lecture others so this one brought here is
henry traffic lights run over the cabin come
out of the affair
[applause]
depression is still public europe the meetings
will be effective  the dressen ware
critic season
well function public
these blaise pascal philosopher republic
out of fear olivia is the last resort
this is new these dolls the alleged
winstead ursula hilbring things and
people to da feng's has focused for
people would like to review
[applause]
[music  ]
[music]
[applause]
thank you
just because
there are others with la crash, the presidium
and madonna gossip, or like the mona
lisa initial, the personnel arg los
[applause]
[music]
the chancellor
new world germany for example
global politics capability demonstrated
global politics capability
you have  managed to truly protect
european interest new european
american must be very very hard not to
forget you so much better than the
impossible investment managers axa
investment managers
und what he hat juni sexy high road not
only when it comes to yuma
[music]
jean claude juncker
jean-claude i can only bow to you in great
gratitude and respect
for what you have done
for our europe it cannot be put
into words but i think everyone
feels at this moment what it
means that we are doing a change of
staff because it is  it's not a farewell you're
staying on the eighth floor we'll
all be seeing you there and so once
again from my side im na  everyone
thank you very much for what you have done for us thank you very much for what you have done
for the europeans thank you very
much for what you have done
for the great idea of europe [appl
use] [musi
] [appl
] [musi
]
[Music]